um cool yeah welcome welcome to this
session about rethinking reactive
architectures um
happy to be here on the last day of this
conference i'm happy to be here even if
it's in a hybrid mode
again in in front of real people not in
front of a zoom call that's fantastic
and yeah greetings also of course to the
people who join online
yeah we're thinking reactive
architectures first things first who am
i i'm david lightning i'm working as a
coding architect in vienna for an
australian company called square
resolutions so we do a lot of you know
work together with big financial
institutes big insurance companies also
a lot of startups and scale ups fintechs
proptex medtechs you know all this kind
of stuff and we do that a lot what i
will talk about today and that's i think
the advantage for you i'm i don't want
to sell you a product i don't want to
sell you a training i'm just just here
to talk a little bit about reactive
architectures because the the guys from
ndc asked me if i want to talk about it
i said yeah ozil is a great city let's
come here
let's give you a little bit of insight
what we experienced with reactive
architecture so that you maybe don't
make the same mistakes as we did um i'm
a traditional guy so if you have any
questions feel free to send me an email
i'm also on on twitter i'm not not
really there i just have an account
there but usually i check my pm so if
anything is unclear afterwards please
free to reach out there and if you want
to see the mountains i'm going up and
down you can also follow me on instagram
um there is basically my personal life
happening
but let's come to the stuff that really
matters
and the stuff that really matters is
obviously reactivity right
and
we see reactivity as a huge buzzword
these days right we see it in many
different aspects of our industry we
have frameworks like like react right
which obviously tend to be reactive
right we have spring reactor which is
kind of a reactive implementation the
java spring ecosystem we have reactive
extension which
originated actually from the net
community and which are broadly
available in nearly all languages
so there's much more on this on this
reactivity on reactive programming and
so the question is what what it is all
about
and the definition of reactivity is very
important for this talk if we talk about
reactive architecture but on the other
hand is also very simple it's basically
about programming and designing upon
asynchronous data streams that that's
what it about right
so we we speak about streams right
finally
everybody loves to speak about streams
and this is the new favorite topic of
everyone we need to stream um we need to
have streams within our architectures
and i still have the feeling and in many
situations people are overwhelmed by
this term right because architects start
to talk about streams and sometimes
people don't fully understand and i
think it's important to to kind of the
illusion this magic behind streams
because the stream is is not a very high
sophisticated concept it's just a data
container basically and if you think
about data containers in modern
programming languages then we usually
have them in two axis right we have them
on the axis of time and we have them on
the axis of space
okay sounds high sophisticated isn't
yeah give give me a second and you will
understand why this explains um streams
very well so in single time or in
singular space and in synchronous time
we have something which we tend to call
a value right
and the value has a get in the center
okay that that's clear every programming
language every modern programming
language these days has a concept for
storing a value
if we go now to plural space right we
have something which we tend to call a
collection and the collection tends to
have an iterator and kind of a generator
and now it's getting a little bit more
interesting because if we move from
synchronous time to asynchronous time
we tend to have something which we tend
to call promise right and and many
modern programming languages these days
come with out-of-the-box support for
promises right and those promises then
usually have a deferred and usually have
a resolver
another question of course is what is on
the left top side right well it's
obvious that's where the stream lives
right and the stream is basically you
can think of it like a collection of
promises right it's something in plural
space and asynchronous time
and the stream that basically has a
subscriber and an emitter and that's a
stream right it's it's just it's just
another data structure the point is just
that many languages many frameworks
didn't treat streams as first-class
citizens so there's not a native
implementation for this data structure
in many programming languages but in a
nutshell it's it's it's clear that it
must exist if you take a look at this
metrics and that's for example where
active extensions jump in right which
which i mentioned earlier which is
basically providing stream
implementation and for different
programming languages
okay so this was a short intro to stream
so that i can be sure that everybody
knows about streams
what has this to do with reactivity well
as i mentioned before reactive
programming is programming with or
deciding upon asynchronous data streams
and i always bring a very simple example
to make this point clear what reactivity
really means and i usually show this
with codes because most of us i guess
are still engineers or had a background
in engineering so most of most of us
would understand this very simply i hope
and
if we take a look at a very simple code
snippet like this one then we have a
variable which is called counter and we
have a variable which is called doubled
and doubled is basically counter
multiplied by two
so it's four right that's that's that's
not that's not hard to compile and to
run in our heads and this test of course
would
would succeed
but what happens now if we change if we
change the value of counter right if we
update it if we set counter to three
well we we assume that doubled is
counter multiplied by two so we could
think that
double should be six of course it isn't
we all know that it isn't right because
if we want to have double to be six we
need to reassign it and we need to
recalculate it and we again need to
assign doubles to counter multiplied by
two
and then it will work right
and that's basically the main criticism
on the of the reactive community on on
the way how we develop or how we design
things right because this relationship
between counter and double this very
implicit here this is an idea that just
exists in our heads we we need to take
care of this we need to know about this
but it shouldn't be like this it should
be very explicit right it should be part
of the language and it should exist over
all time actually right so we want to
basically bind counter and doubled and
one guy who realized this very well in
the blog post is paul stovall he wrote a
great article on a very similar subject
about reactive programming and he
introduced something which he tends to
call the destiny operator and the
destiny operator is the thing to bind in
our case counter
and doubled and how does this look like
well
just you know it's just a simple concept
we say okay we introduce here now the
destiny operator and that's that's him
right it's just a little bit a little
bit a different assignment and when we
say we we make a destiny operator
basically whenever we change counter
this will also update our doubled value
right
and with this destiny probably basically
project the counter value into our
doubled value and this would then
probably work of course it's a
theoretical concept and in reality if
you want to achieve this this is always
working with streams so we always get
kind of this binding by utilizing
streams and in obsidor this would look
like this we have a stream with the
initial value of two right so our
counter stream has a value of two
when we have another stream then we
basically take the value of counter and
map it and multiply it by two right so
we have a second stream which is then
called doubled and this is a value of
four
so
and that's important now we project the
data from our counter stream into our
double stream that's what we basically
do and we'll come back to this later
and then we can update our stream of
course and we do this by emitting a new
value so we go to counter emit value
three right this leads to effect that
counter has a new value has an
additional value in its stream and this
will automatically of course also update
our double stream and then we can say
you know
doubled value is six right
and that's reactive programming in a
nutshell and this was all solder code
but in reality it would look very
similar right if you for example take
reactive extensions and if you would
implement the same thing with reactive
extensions we would say okay we have a
behavior subject behavior subject is
basically just a stream with an initial
value of two right and then we can say
you know we derive from this stream
another stream and we take the counter
stream map it multiply it by two and
whenever we change the counter we just
emit a new value
and doubled value would then be six this
this test would work so it would really
be green and more modern frameworks like
for example svelte which is which
popular these days in the in the web
development
they they even took this concept of the
destiny operator further and they really
implemented kind of a destiny operator
what they do is they say you know we
have a variable counter which is two
and we have a variable
doubled which is counter multiplied by
two and you see this this tiny little
whoa
you see this tiny little prefix here
this dollar sign
and this dollar sign basically tells us
that this is reactive value
this will change whenever something that
affects this value changes so when we
then assign three to counter the search
to double the six will still be true
and again this will work and basically
that's reactive programming that that's
what you
need to understand about this right
and now we basically come to the to the
topic of this talk because these
concepts and that's why i'm so eager on
people to understand these concepts
these concepts of reactive programming
can also play be applied on reactive
architectures or architectures in
general as well
okay
let's get this started so
as i mentioned i work a lot in in
financial institutes and we of course do
a lot of distributed systems and stuff
like this so i took a example use case
from from from project which kind of
looked similar which i've worked for a
while ago and let's assume we have a few
services right we have a user service
and then we have an account service so
basically the user is the client the
customer of a bank and the user can have
multiple accounts and this accounts that
basically can trigger transactions and
transactions are usually stored in
something which tend to call ledger
right so very very simple example and
then we have a web banking application
okay and from this web
banking application we can tweak a new
payment and i can say i want to transfer
20 euros from my account to lisa's
account and if i click on perform the
payment it will go to the user account
and will say hey transfer the money from
one user to another this will basically
trigger payment against the account
service
and then actually this will trigger
an transaction on the ledger and if all
this works fine we get back all the
responses everything good everything
great the payment was successfully
executed
it never works like this unfortunately
right that's the happy happy happy path
right in most situations um we have with
a different scenario we trigger a new
payment
we create um this payment and basically
we create transactions and they have
ledger
and
most people who ever work with a later
know that ledgers are yeah they've kind
of special systems right and at some
point in time they're maybe kind of lazy
they have high latency they don't want
to answer you whatever right and this
ultimately leads to this loading right
to this kind of loading stuff all the
time and if you've ever been sitting in
front of your pc
and did a payment
and you were waiting for this payment to
be executed and you're stuck with a
loading screen this makes you really
nervous right this is just a bad user
experience
and this can take some time so let me
quickly drink something
in the meantime and
once once the ledger is maybe back yeah
it could be back in the best case in the
worst case it runs in the timeout or
whatever once the ledger could be back
we of course get back some kind of this
information and the payment was executed
successfully and even if this works it's
still it's still very bad right but in
many situations
in many situations it doesn't really
work and that's why we try to start to
solve this problem with retries we know
all the things right with retries with
timeouts with kind of circuit breakers
and that's kind of sophisticated because
we need to start to synchronize all this
stuff right because if the ledger
engineer says okay our timeout is after
one minute right and if the account
engineer says you know we retry every
five seconds if lazy later doesn't
answer right then we run into this
problem that you basically did was your
own system right and this yeah you don't
want to be waked up in the middle of the
night by a call
um which which tells you hey our system
is ddos and then you basically find out
um that it's your own services because
you didn't synchronize with retries and
timers and all this stuff so
very complicated it never really worked
for us it's just just a pain in the ass
to be honest and that's kind of the
first um generation of microservices i
would say this this heavily
synchronously integrated microservices
and we find out that it doesn't work
right and that's why we started to take
a look at this example and realized we
need to integrate this differently right
and this is when we basically didn't
talk directly from the account to the
ledger but introduced a queue in between
so we said okay you know here's the
queue now and whenever a payment is
triggered we take this payment and
basically forward it to the queue
and when it's stored in the queue we're
basically done because the queue
guarantees is that at some point in time
when the ledger is ready it will start
to process it and that's i think that's
common sense these days but it's
important to understand that here
reverting now changed right we didn't
execute the payment we accepted the
payment so in terms of http codes we
switched from 201 to 202 right so we we
told the customer okay we accept that
you payment we will work on it but yeah
come back later and check if it's
already done and once the ledger is then
available he will pick up the message
and we will execute the payment of
course and this of course already helps
yeah this makes the system more
resilient um and and and helps us in
decoupling from from high latency
services and you know the rule of of
bottlenecks is if you use isolate one
bottleneck you will spot the next one
right so maybe we spot okay there's an
issue between user and account
communication and if you spot this
bottleneck and solve it you find another
bottleneck right and ultimately there's
letters then unto this effect that we
kind of built heavily asynchronously
integrated services and this were the
big times of tools like rabbit and queue
and active mq and all this stuff right
and that's kind of the second generation
of asynchronously integrated
microservices and as i mentioned it
solves quite a couple of problems um
which which we had before in only
synchronously integrated services
but there's big elephant in this room
here right there's big problem there's a
big downside of this general design
and you will realize this problem when
you talk to your product owner when you
talk to your po right because your po
will tell you you know what it's
important that as a customer i want a
transaction to be booked by the ledger
this is what no po will ever tell you
right
as a customer you don't care where
transaction is booked right you don't
care if it's booked in the ledger or if
it's booked somewhere else right and
your po will also not say you know as a
customer i want my account service to
update my balance
you don't care where this is happening
as a customer you just want to have a
correct balance at the end of the day
what a po would probably tell you is
that as a customer i want to transfer
money to someone else
and then you say okay that makes sense
that's
kind of a yeah
we could probably do this is bang yeah
it could make sense to implement this
feature and then you start to realize
okay i will i will try to understand how
we do this in our implementation and
then you need to go to the user team to
the user service team and say hey you
know we have this new crazy requirement
to trigger payment can you please extend
your api and points can you take this
payment and then forward it to the
account service to the guys from the
account service and i will talk to them
and they will tell them hey please can
you extend your api we need
the availability to create um kind of
payments and the the user service will
trigger you and and you need to then
take this request and forward it to the
ledger and at some point in time the
ledger will maybe send you back a
transaction talk to the ledger and
define the swagger apis and all this
stuff and then you need to go to the
ledger team and say hey you know there's
this new
user story where we need to implement
this transaction on the ledger side can
you do this and you know you get called
by the account and the account got
called by the user and you just
okay this doesn't really work this
doesn't make as fast this doesn't really
make us hr and this doesn't allow us to
deliver fast user value or customer
value and that's what we tend to see
very often still these days this entity
service anti-pattern right and that's a
big problem in micro service
architecture is that people
take you know the entities from the
database and say okay we have a user we
have a bank account we have transactions
so build those services around it but
that's not what we really want to do
right what we want to do is we want to
create services along customer journeys
right and i had the pleasure to talk on
wednesday
to to to a
old friend of mine i would say i met him
with a couple of conferences already um
trot he had a had a great talk i think
he also yesterday and he showed me a
very interesting paper and this paper is
interesting because it's from 1972 and
he talks about um the the the criteria
how we should modularize um systems
right or decompose systems and it's from
from 1972 from from partners and he
already stated in this paper from 1972
that we shouldn't structure our
applications based on process steps but
we should structure them based on main
trend flows right
so it took us half a decade to
re-understand this in microservice
architectures again but yeah finally we
are there so yeah
better better late than never but that
that's that's the idea right so we want
to create services along customer
journeys
and when you get this requirement as
engineers you know engineers are clever
clever guys right that's why they're
engineers and what we do then is we say
okay yeah we do not customer journeys
but we still you know we need this
entity data so we basically often just
rename this domain services and in front
of those domain services we build our
beautiful customer journeys right so
there is
no problem in software engineering which
you cannot solve in an additional layer
and that's also true here so this
payment service then we usually would
call the user service would call the
account service with co trigger
transaction the ledger service and the
web application web banking application
ultimately would call this one and then
you have a team which is taking care of
this customer journey service
and we see all these dependencies right
we have kind of this upstream um
dependency that leads to the ripple
effect so whenever for example the
accounting service is down right it will
directly impact our payment service or
when the ledger service is down it will
if the user service is done it will
directly impact our payment service so
it's not fun to work in the payment
service team right and
if we go back to our po and say yeah no
we reshuffle our architecture we now
work with customer journalists can you
tell me again what you needed ah okay it
was about this this this this payments
this transfer of money well let me think
okay i need to go to payments team i
need to go use it okay
didn't really improve the situation
right i need to go to four teams now
instead of three and even worse many
many projects i've been in started to
utilize the back and forth front and
back and which is a very great pattern
for specific use cases
to implement the customer journeys right
so we have the customer journey of
payment and in the web backend for
front-end right and then we have more
back-end for front-ends for example a
mobile backend for front-end for mobile
clients right
and we then implement their the payment
flow as well and this leads to a lot of
duplication right of this payment logic
and that's actually what we don't want
to have to duplicate business logic and
then ultimately this is owned i guess by
a different team usually the team that
also owns the the mobile applications
and then basically all even gets worse
right you need to go to five teams now
and and you get the point right so
especially that's why i brought this on
the slides because i see this often this
misusage of of doing this kind of
customer journeys in our back in for
frontlines that's not the idea of back
end for frontends that's not what sam
newman defines in this pattern right so
back and for frontlines are not about
domain logic right they are just about
aggregating together data and bringing
it into shape how we expect it on the
mobile client mainly to avoid
over-fetching and mainly to avoid
over-requesting but more about defining
customer journeys there okay but yeah
let's get back to the problem of
customer journeys right so this was the
issue well um and if we have now
multiple customer journals let's say we
have another customer attorney which
shows us our current balance and shows
our latest transactions then this
customer journey obviously also has
dependencies to a ledger to get on the
latest transaction and maybe also has a
dependency to account and this then on
the long term leads to a lot of
resilience issues right because if
account is down
and if we cannot access the account data
this will have a direct impact on our
balance and our payments customer
journey
and there's a big underlying problem
behind this we kind of all aware a
little bit of this i have the feeling
and if i talk to people they fully
understand this but the underlying
problem is what i tend to call this
mismatch of customer journeys and entity
data right so there seems to be kind of
a mismatch and if we think about entity
data each system has entity data we
cannot really avoid to have this right
so we have for example users we have
accounts we have transactions
and on the other hand we have these
customer journeys right we have payment
we have non-boarding we have fraud
detection stuff like this
and the interesting part is now this
relationship between customer charges
entities because it turns out for
example that payments would use a would
need a user would need an account would
need a transaction right
and onboarding would again need a user
and would again need accounts and fraud
detection probably only needs accounts
and transactions
and we see this is not a one-to-one
relationship or want-to-end relationship
this is an end-to-end relationship and
this turns out to make things very hard
because if we then design our system
like we did before then we end up
ultimately always in this kind of
distributed monolith um which which
makes everything really hard and yeah it
doesn't really bring that much value
so how could we solve this issue well we
could easily say yeah that let's get rid
of the entity services or the domain
services let's move the entities into
the customer journeys right so on a
theoretical level could look like this
the onboarding um service now has user
accounts the payment services user
accounts and payments and so on and so
forth
but you know this would first of all
make our services very autonomous very
independently so if payment service
doesn't work this has no direct impact
on fraud detection or onboarding that's
fine we have high service autonomy but i
mean as you already see we have a lot of
data duplication here right so we have
account on three different services
spread and you will have a lot of data
synchronization problems
and
that's that's important now because when
when i talk to people and when we talk
about distributed systems i often have
the feeling that that's not clear but it
should be very clear
we should very explicitly define who
owns data in our distributed systems
right this is very often just an
implicit definition somebody makes at
some point in time but it should be very
explicitly defined who owns which data
along our distributed system
and we could easily define this here we
could say you know onboarding owns the
user payment owns the account and
transactions right and when we for
example need a user in payments then we
go to onboarding and fetch the user data
from there but then again we have to
synchronous calls right we didn't want
to have them because if onboarding is
down we have a problem in executing
payments and then people start to
introduce caching and you know all this
stuff and you have two big problems in
software engineering naming and and
cache invalidation and off by one errors
and it just doesn't really work it
doesn't really make sense makes it a
very complex thing which should be which
should be much more simple and so there
must be a better solution to get around
this mismatch of customer journeys and
entity data
and it turns out that there is one right
um it turns out if we think back what i
said in the in the in the very beginning
when we took a look at the simple code
snippets
then i said one sentence we project the
data from our customer stream into our
double stream and this concept of
projecting data from one
place to another place could also help
us in this direction so if we think of
our onboarding of our onboarding service
who owns the user and our payment
service who needs a user then we could
think of it that in the payment service
we want a projection
of the onboarding user
so we would like to project from
onboarding to payment right
our kind of users and if we think this
in ddd terms then we would say we have
on the one hand side a user aggregate
and from this user aggregate we project
into our user read model and then we
have whenever the user aggregate changes
we have a user event and this actually
triggers the user read model to be
updated and when we want to update the
user we have a user command and the
payment service would probably trigger
this user commands to update the user
aggregates would then again create an
event this event would update the read
model and that's basically a cqs in a
nutshell and we get this done by
utilizing streams right
because this event goes into a stream
and again as we did in the very simple
codesync but we could even use stream
transformations we could say we
transform the user from onboarding
because the user in onboarding has 50
fields right but we in payments just
need five of them so we kind of map it
and get rid of 45 shuffle these five in
a way format them in a way that we can
simply read them for the payment use
cases and that's basically where we
switch to technologies like apache kafka
apache pools are right
and our use case that's that can be
achieved again very simple
we can say you know if a user gets
updated we trigger an event we store
this event that the user got updated
into our stream right so we move it
there from there on we forward it to the
payment service and then the payment
service we then basically store it in
our user read model and if the user
changes again we can basically do the
same thing and the event
would again update the user right and we
can do this basically for nearly all
data we have in here like transactions
which we can push to the stream
and whoever needs a reprojection of
these transactions can directly read it
from the stream but it's important to
understand that you know this is just
read data this is data which we don't
want to manipulate anymore if we want to
change users we will always go via
commands or wire requests to our
onboarding service and then people
usually ask isn't this event sourcing
well
it could be yeah
let's let's go a little bit into detail
to understand this question because it's
a very good question
um well if we do this what i just showed
you that we kind of get events and this
event should update for example the
state in our onboarding service in
addition it should also trigger an event
to our event stream
then we usually have this problem that
if one of those two doesn't work we
cannot really revert the other one right
so for example if we send an event to
our stream and the stream said okay cool
i got it and then we tried to save the
state change to our database and our
database for whatever reason doesn't
allow it then we can really get back the
event which you already published to the
stream and you can turn it around
however you want you you get into this
problem and this problem is caused by
the by the by the issue that we of
course don't have transactions over
streams and databases right so we don't
have this concept of being transactional
here so we can never ensure that data
for sure lands in both in both in both
persistence so to say
and the solution to this problem is
basically something people do very often
so we go
when we get a user update we take it we
store it in our database and our
database then updates the user table but
also updates in the same transaction the
user events table and this is what we
tend to call than usually the outbox
table so we trigger an and record into
this user events table
and we can ensure that both these
records are stored in the database right
so we can ensure this because we have a
transaction over um this kind of two to
two updates or to create statements in
our database
and then we basically just go to the
user events and we kind of stream them
into our stream and this is usually done
by change data capture or you implement
the watchdog or you implement manually
rescue a rescued
a process which takes your user events
table all the time and understands
basically if there's something changed
and we publish it to the stream right
and that's what we tend to call the
objects pattern and this is a pattern to
solve this issue which i showed you
before but for my opinion it's heavily
overused i wrote a blog post on this if
you're more interested in this why we
shouldn't overuse the outbox pattern too
much because there are much more simple
ways to achieve this and another way to
achieve this is if we get a user update
event we basically just forward it to
the stream
and then we say okay we're done we have
it in a stream
and then on the other side we listen to
our own event and we say okay use
updated event that's also interesting
for me right i take basically the user
and update it in there and that's what
we tend to call the listen to ourselves
or listen to yourself pattern right we
really listen to our own events and
there kind of get rid of this this
transactional boundary and don't need to
implement an outbox and all this stuff
and another option and now we get to
event sourcing is basically event
sourcing to solve this problem right and
event sourcing for those who don't know
is basically that we sum up all the
events within the system and those
events of the system are kind of the
current state of our application that's
that's kind of the idea and i always
explain this with transactions because
it's very simple if you have a couple of
transactions so you have a transaction
which gives you 20 euros and you have a
transaction which gives you another 10
years and you have a transaction where
you have to pay five euros and you have
another transaction where you get seven
years then based on these events you
could always kind of understand your
current balance so after the first
transaction your balance is plus 20
euros right after the second balan after
the second transaction your balance is
blocked 30 years after your third
balance you after your third transaction
so your balance is 25 euros and then
basically the balance is 32 euros so the
important stuff here is that we move the
source of truth to the left-hand side so
the source of truths are our events and
based on these events we can always
derive our current state so we wouldn't
store the balance in the table and we
wouldn't update the balance there we
would just store the events and based on
these events we can always calculate the
balance and event sourcing is of course
a very interesting topic and we could
have a separate talk on the downsides
and the challenges but also on the big
advantages but basically the idea is
simple as that right and if a new
transaction happens yeah again we can
update the balance and we can say it's
not 35.
and
implemented
is of course with streams in most
scenarios so we can easily say that an
onboarding a service now gets this user
updated event we just store it in a
stream and basically whoever is
interested in those events in those user
information can build up its read model
based on those events right and we can
have here an onboarding a user and we
know it's ages 21 and when we're
interested in the age of users also an
advertisement service we can basically
also consume it there and store it in
our read model
and then of course we can trigger new
events we can say okay the user is not
22 right and then basically we can
update um
the user agent both services and we will
have then the user age 22 everywhere
right and somebody else could really get
changed so somebody from the outside
could say okay the user should now be 23
and so on and so forth
and that's what i tend to call global
event sourcing and i'm not a big fan of
global event sourcing because from my
perspective it breaks the boundaries of
information hiding and lots of data
isolation so what i usually try to
recommend is when we do event sourcing
we do something which we tend to call
local event sourcing so very similar
concept but our onboarding service gets
a command to update the user right we
kind of store this um command as an
event in our stream so the user got
updated is now 21 and we basically
forward this event then to our global
stream to our published stream which
everybody can read from and basically we
have this event in here and even if this
is the same kafka cluster in the end
right it doesn't really matter but i
think it's very important that we say
this event store is owned by a
particular service otherwise you end up
in you know this kind of database
integration which we had a decade ago
and which we didn't really like and now
you would say okay basically that's the
same you just have two streams now right
you make things more complex but i think
we gain a lot of benefits here right
because first of all we can ensure some
kind of business rules on onboarding we
can say you know a user isn't allowed to
have a negative age a user isn't allowed
to be older than 200 years and so on and
so forth right and we have this
information hiding and and we hide also
that the implementation details so if at
some point anytime we say you know event
sourcing is a great idea but doesn't
make sense in this particular use case
or just replace it with a bosco stp and
change data capture our changes from
postgres to the stream then we can
easily do this and last but not least
you see we didn't update or we didn't
publish the same event from our local
event store to the global event stream
because we can customize it we can say
you know i don't want to actually expose
the data how i store it internally
because maybe it's not not easy to read
maybe it's not easy to understand we
publish another event we publish a user
age changed event which is easy to
consume which is easy to interpret
by users
and that's basically that's basically
the idea and event sourcing both kinds
of event sourcing solve this problem
which we can solve with the outbooks
better or to listen to yourself better
so too long don't read eventually can be
used but it's not mandatory yeah that's
what i what i want to what i want to
what i want to say here because i often
have the feeling that if people start to
think kind of a little bit reactive they
always think it must be red sourcing
doesn't have to be and if you go with
event sourcing my advice
prefer local over global event sourcing
and
well
if we if we now go back to this initial
problem right
then we see that this this idea of of
this reactivity which we introduced in
our system architecture already solved
couple of issues because when we now
have the onboarding service being down
and we cannot
kind of access user data we don't need
to do this during executing payments
because we have kind of projected all
the user data we need for payments into
our payment service so that that's an
important concept we co-locate the
business logic with the data right so we
try to make everything available at
runtime so we don't want to pull for
users during runtime when new payment
should be executed but we want to get
the users pushed into our services right
because this makes our system more
resilient and i show you a use case to
make this a little bit more
understandable maybe so five years ago
around five years ago i worked for from
big austrian bank and we we
recreated the mobile banking there
and well makes of course a lot of sense
to first understand what do we actually
need and we did some research and it
turned out that if you build mobile
banking right 93 percent of the users
what they basically do with this app
most of the time is checking the current
balance and checking the latest
transactions maybe you see yourself if
you take out your phone and check mobile
banking that's basically what you do
right so that's 93 percent of all the
time users spend on your application is
basically they will do this two simple
things checking your current balance and
checking your latest transactions and
then they initiate some new payments and
and other fun any other functionality
like you know locking your card all this
stuff it takes you
months to implement and then basically
is used nearly never um so also from an
agile perspective or from a
prioritization perspective are very
important or interesting numbers but in
the context of software architecture we
can use these numbers very well
and we can really build our application
in a way that it supports those numbers
so we could basically say you know if a
user triggers payment yeah simple as
that it goes to a transaction the
transaction stored in a stream and is
stored in the database and from there on
we move this transaction over the stream
the overview service consumes this
transaction stores it is in a read model
and this read model can also be
persisted of course so maybe we store
the transactions here on the overview
service
as a persistent read model and then when
a web application a mobile or web
banking wants to read our current
transactions and balances then we
basically just go to this warm
persistence here we never go back to the
payment service to read current balances
and latest transactions we always only
just go to this tiny read model which is
persisted here and this brings a lot of
advantages when it comes to resilience
because you can start to burn your own
boarding service you can even start to
burn your payment service you can
basically start to burn nearly your
whole architecture right
but as long as the overuser service is
available
you will be able to serve
of what the customer needs from you and
this is reading latest transactions
reading current balances yeah maybe this
data gets stale after some seconds right
but you can still deliver the customer
and experience that he can check his
current balance and your application
isn't down or doesn't send back a 500
right
and there are multiple more advantages
if you think in this kind of reversing
from pool to push if you think in this
kind of reactive patterns in
architecture and another advantage is
that we can easily horizontally scale
right we can spin up a second overview
service and this over a few servers when
it spins up it basically builds up again
this read model so we build up a read
model and we have an independent
instance of the overview service and we
can then from our web banking
application read from both services and
if one of them fails then we can easily
deal with this problem because we can
easily horizontally scale and that's a
big advantage of course and there are
even more advantages right in terms of
resilience we have you know this this
kind of autonomous services and this
horizontal scaling but also in terms of
of user experience if we take the
concept of a payment right then for
example in the web banking of lisa she
triggers payments to transfer 20 euros
to me this goes over our kind of http
request to the payment service we store
the transaction in the in the stream
this transaction gets forwarded to the
to the overview service we store idea in
the read model and basically we can
directly push it forward down to the ui
right and now you see how should this
work right because we push it down and
the ui basically takes care of this and
and shows the transaction without any f5
or something like this or any reload
it's it's really pushed from end to end
and now you're saying well you know
that's not really working because we
have rest here and rest is pull based
right and in many situations that's true
but you could for example use something
like server-side events or web sockets
and in these situations we often use
graphql for example because it's a
perfect fit there because graphql
defines subscriptions as first-class
citizens yeah in graphql you can vary
data and you can subscribe to data and
whenever something changes and you have
a subscription you will directly get
these changes pushed right
and that's why i always say graphql is
beautiful when you only work with
mutations and subscriptions right so you
mutate data and this will trigger a lot
of subscriptions and there is no concept
of you know caching or reloading needed
you really get data pushed end to end
and this is what what we tend to call
entrained reactive systems and this out
of the box real-time capabilities are
really great in many in many in many
aspects or in many domains
and one last thing which this kind of
architecture enables is that we can
easily
okay not easily but we have a way um to
strangle down monoliths for example
because you know every system kind of
has this legacy core or this legacy
systems which we need to deal with them
and that's tough right and even tough
ways to work with the data from those
systems and usually those systems for
example store the user right and in this
situation this is working um with
streams and working in a reactive way
enables us to easily or more easily
decompose these monoliths right so we
could for example use change data
capture and what i mentioned already
before is the change data capture is
nothing else then each database kind of
keeps an event source in its in in its
database so we could easily check what
what changed over the time and we could
consume these events with tools like the
bcm or other change data capture tools
and forward whenever a user was changed
in the user table in our database to our
event stream and from there we can then
consume them in newly created services
right newly fully independent services
which are not affected by down times or
by problems in the legacy services
because we can push the data from our
legacy into our new service and that's
as mentioned a very interesting concept
when it comes to
to a monolith decomposition we could
also do this the other way around but
yeah of course in reality it's much more
complex than it's here shown on the
slides i mean that's i guess true for
most of the slides i showed you um but
in in the context of of migration of
course but
we when we and we do a lot of monolithic
composition projects these days
we usually always use change to the
capture not only but it's it's really an
important tool in our strategies to
decompose
monoliths
and that's kind of the last generation
or the current generation the third
generation of microservice which we tend
to call fully reactive right so we have
this advantage of being high resilient
we have horizontal scaling we can have
real-time integration and we have even
good integration with legacy systems
but we have a few minutes left and i
would talk a little bit about scaling
because there's even
another another generation of micro
services and if we talk about scaling
then we're all aware of those dimensions
of scaling right we know that these two
dimensions the one is vertical the other
one is horizontal and usually we have a
service and we can scale it up
vertically so we can put more cpu we
could put more memory we could put more
disk space on it but actually that's not
the way we want to go because it turns
out to be very cost intensive on the
cloud and things like this so we usually
want to go with horizontal scaling so we
want not to
increase the power of one service but we
want to have multiple instances of the
service running right i think that's
kind of the the classical knowledge um
when we talk about cloud native
architectures
and that's usually where yeah where
everybody is aware of and and where we
usually stop but it's interesting that
we have a third dimension of scaling
and the third dimension of scaling is
usually called charting
and what does this mean now we can chart
our services right we don't only can
horizontally scale our services we can
also sharpen them so we could for
example say we put charts on those
services and those charts are basically
defined by user groups right so we can
say the first user group goes to this
service the second user group goes to
this service and the third user group
goes to this service and we can then
combine those things and we can change
the user groups maybe based on countries
but still we can horizontally scale we
can say you know in norway we have a lot
of users so we need to spin up a second
service in great britain we even have
more service more users so we need to
spin up more and more services and this
concept of sharding is very important
when you take reactive architectures a
step further because ultimately what you
have is you have a user event right so a
user triggered a payment and this user
event gets stored into a stream
and now all kind of common streaming
platforms like apache kafka like apache
pools even if you use a radius for for
for kind of pops up or or streaming
then they work with the concept of
shards they usually tend to call it
partitions redis for example even calls
it shards but kafka and pulse and most
of the others call them partitions and
basically your event goes into a
specific
partition and that's usually defined
based on a user key or whatever you
define for your petitioning and that's
basically sharding so we take this event
and move it into one partition right and
from there on we have the uncharted
services we have for example three
instances of our services
which
listen to different charts in our
architecture and we can say you know for
this user group it will always go into
partition one and we will always have to
service listening to the partition one
and from there we can forward it we can
say okay we make um fraud detection
or basically you create um um event that
the valid is paying that the payment is
valid and from there on we consume it
again in a shouted way by a fraud
detection this fraud detection then
again creates an event and says hey
please um the payment is checked let's
execute it and the ledger is then again
sharded you know the ledger is charted
in the way that only parts of the ledger
work with parts of our user base and
then basically we can take this folder
and move it into a stream which is
ultimately that
the transaction stream where all
transactions which were booked are
stored
and the important part is now if the
fraud detection services they usually
need transaction information right and
we can easily project this data back of
course from this from this transaction
topic into our fraud detection and
the important part is that we really
just need to stay into our shards
because we can always ensure that in one
shot there is a specific user and the
user will always be in the same chart so
we don't need to stream back all our
kind of transactions we just really need
to stream back um the transaction from
the chart win and this of course makes
the system
much more scalable and and much more
performant right
and tools we usually use here for this
kind of streaming architectures think
after streams or apache think and from
there on we can then basically move
those events forwards to a data sync and
for example elasticsearch is a good data
sync for transactions right and the
elastic search again works internally
with sha doesn't really matter now but
the scale also with with the concept of
charts but we can then for example go to
this elastic search and consume the
transactions from our web banking from
there and this kind of makes this system
super resilient and also makes it kind
of
fantastic when it comes to throughput
yeah you can push massively data through
this system yeah it's
not really possible to break the system
i worked for an australian financial
institute and we built an application
charted with 24 partitions based on
kafka so we had 24 instances right
sharded in a way that
that could not be that much traffic
basically um that you that you really
kind of um break this architecture and
that's of course very powerful it's also
very complex but when it comes um to the
to the to the to the scale and when it
comes to the throughput this is
i think you cannot really you cannot
really find a way um to get this more
performant and that's kind of the latest
obviously architectural strength when it
comes to microservices which we tend to
call stream based to start it in in a
very stream based approach
and this of course creates massive
throughput um this allows us extended
extreme scalability right
and we're nearly at the end so let's
let's sum up here
i know this was a lot of tough stuff i
hope
you kind of were able to follow but i
wanted to bring in this as much as
possible to give you this overview of
the different kind of architectural
patterns we see emerging on a
microservice scale
and let's let's sum up here now so
an important thing which i didn't
mention and i mentioned in the beginning
that i work a lot with with startups and
and scale-ups and and stuff like this
and
all of them have one thing in common
they started with the monolith right
and i know it always depends but i i
tell you if you if you do something
start with a monolith right that's what
i can probably say for sure
start with the monolith it's the best
way to start right because if those
startups would have started with stream
based or reactive architectures they
would have invested all the time in this
technical details but didn't deliver
business value so first of all very
important i guess you all know start
with a monolith this model that grows
over time right
then we maybe need to split this
monolith and the way to split it is
splitting it synchronously as we have
seen in the beginning
don't do this
just don't do it it creates pain it
doesn't create any benefit actually you
always end up in a distributed monolith
just just really don't do this if if you
need to kind of split it sink then of
going with a with a model lid right so a
well-defined monolith
and if at some point in time this
doesn't work for you anymore because you
need to have multiple processes then
maybe think of
integrating or splitting up your system
in a synchronous way right
and then at some point in time you will
automatically run into this problem of
shared data
and then you need to twist right
so you need to to shift the dependency
or the data flow actually and you will
and ultimately always end up in kind of
reactive systems because you want your
data to be pushed to the downstreams and
not pull from the downstreams so
basically that's what reactivity is
about right moving from pool to push and
if this is still not enough and if you
still need more performance more
throughput then you could think of of
the streaming architecture i showed you
very shortly in the end
and this allows us massive throughput so
always start on the left hand side and
try to migrate from left to right right
and there are fantastic reasons to go to
the right hand side don't don't get me
wrong fantastic reasons like
availability resilience scalability
throughput all these things
but they're also very bad reasons to go
to the right-hand side right and of
course it's always in software
architecture we pay with complexity so
my advice start on the left hand side
and always think twice how far to the
right you have to go
that was it this was about reactive
architectures i hope i made you re-think
in reactive architectures hope this was
useful thanks a lot
[Applause]
i think we're a little bit out of time
right
and
but yeah if you if you have any
questions feel free um to ask him now if
we have time left or yeah reach out
afterwards i'm here for the rest of
today one more thing oh i didn't nearly
forgot um we do a a a community training
so free community training on reactive
architectures i think somewhere next
week um so we will dive a little bit
more into this concept which i showed
you on state stores projections
streaming and so on but really more
hands-on so kind of
kind of coding this stuff um so maybe
this could be a good fit to what i told
you
in this talk so far about reactive
architectures
any questions
well
that's a tough question right when do we
when is the right time to to split up a
monolith right
and i would say it's better late than
too early um but of course at some point
in time it creates a lot of pain right
and usually you anyway feel it right if
you have usually startups you see they
started with one team and then at some
point in time they have five teams and
if still five teams still need to work
all on the same monotone cold pace then
it's usually time to split up right and
then again
based on customer return it's very
important don't take out entities take
out customer journeys and take out those
customer journals which bring the most
value and where you need scaling for
example trading a payment in a bank or
in a in a fintech right and i would move
them out and i would try to keep them
very independent in the beginning would
really just make asynchronous
integration there and then when we need
kind of more
data integration between those separate
services then we need any way to become
reactive because we need to push data
right and then there's the way to go
then
for example payment is a gold example
because then you could even take this
further and move it to streaming because
in payment you can have the demands for
high scalability and high throughput
yeah
did this out of your question
yeah okay that's a tough question when
when do you move to the right basically
on this diagram i showed you in the end
and that's
a lot of companies die on these
decisions honestly they die because they
can't get don't get rid of the monolith
so they cannot produce business value in
an acceptable time anymore and others
start too early so they die because they
do not produce business value anymore
because they invest all the time and you
know decomposing monoliths and yeah
building you know beautiful
micro service architecture without any
without any real business purpose yeah
cool
i think we're done have a great
conference it was nice to be here and
yeah stay safe
you